one of the cool things about the game is
that we we're trying to capture the feel
of the films so what we've tried to do
is build our
our maps and our battle structures so
that they are generally plain aligned
like the film but at the same time
it's space so you can do whatever you
want so like as a bomber
it is perfectly valid to fly upside down
beneath the star destroyer and be
launching your bombs upward into the
base of the ship
it lets you have a kind of have your
cake and eat it too in terms of feeling
like star wars
but giving you a lot of control hi this
is ian frazier creative director on star
wars squadrons hi
i'm shadi malek lead ui artist on star
wars squadrons
and this is every starfighter in star
wars squadrons
[Music]
fundamentally star wars squadrons is a
game about being a pilot a combat pilot
in the star wars universe
so you're going to get into iconic ships
like the x-wing and the tie fighter
blast around and 5v5 space battles both
in single player we've got a story set
after return of the jedi
and a multiplayer where we have two
different competitive modes so today
we're going to look at all 10 playable
ships in star wars squadrons
we're going to have an in-depth look at
their design gameplay and how we stay
true to the films the fighter class is
the multi-role class within star wars
squadrons so these are the ships that
are good at everything but they're not
great at any one thing
if you want to be flexible able to
switch back and forth between offense
and defense
fighters are where it's at the cool
thing with the tie fighter is
it's one of the ships where we have a
lot of references from the films
for any of the eight ships we would
always start by the movies
that's like the holy grail we would
supplement that by looking at schematics
drawings in various manuals that we had
grabbing
all of that we would do first concept
art in 2d
so this is really just like in photoshop
grabbing different parts moving them
around rescaling them
addressing all our gameplay needs but
making sure that we stayed true to star
wars aesthetic
and the vehicle's specific character so
for the tie fighter
it's a ship that actually does have
already a nice big central screen
and we just had to kind of manipulate a
few elements that were already existing
in the cockpit
to go and create the extra gameplay
elements we needed we tried to act like
we were
income like we were sign our fleet
systems like we were the fictional
companies within the star wars universe
that builds these ships we're looking at
it partially as game developers but
partially also from a purely fictional
lens and going
well if you had to really build one of
these ships for real what would you do
running this mixture between the films
and trying to capture the prop
but then knowing that the prop is a prop
and then looking at what it would take
to really fly one of these things
and then finally knowing that well it's
a game so there's constraints around
that as well
we try to take all those things together
to end up with the result that you see
today
the biggest challenge with getting the
tie fighter to to play the way that we
wanted
was simply that the design of it is
actually uh built around this sort of
porthole window right you have this
front-facing window that everything's
focused around
and we need to make sure the player has
enough vision frankly
so there was a lot of playing with the
distance between where that window is
where the control column is where your
seat is
so that both in 2d and of course in vr
that the amount of visibility you have
there is kind of maximized
well we keep the iconic look fun fact as
we were working on it we ran into a
problem
the tie fighter interior where the
struts are in the window
don't match the exterior there was
actually a production error in the new
hope
so the inside of the tie doesn't match
up with the outside the angle of the
struts is different we had to decide
okay which which of these is going to be
correct of course being a pilot game
focused within the cockpit we chose the
cockpit view we needed for gameplay to
have additional screens
so we have a central console but we've
got a lot of gameplay components we
didn't want it to be
2d ui overlay we want players to have
that pilot fantasy of really using the
instruments that are in the ship
we had to add screens we were looking at
a reference that was outside the period
and if you look at first order
ties they have these arms inside with
like these triangular screens
the discussion we had from there is like
well you know this is not the right time
period it's not the right model we don't
want to go there
but could we maybe imagine that there is
a prototype of it that's already around
in our timeline that's one of the nice
things with our time period is we're
right after endor so both sides are kind
of reappraising what they're doing a
little bit
and we see some interesting technology
involved that makes sense fictionally
with the ties specifically you'll notice
that in the prologue which is set around
the same time period as the first film
you don't have any missiles you don't
have any countermeasures you have the
basic
lasers engines tie fighter but then when
we jump forward to the post endor period
where most of the game is set
now that the titan squadron the imperial
group that you're with
they start experimenting with these
ships and trying things that are a
little bit more out there
so you're going to get some non-stock
options for weapons and components and
stuff
once you get into that later time period
the x-wing and the tie fighter needed to
be quite different
this is a game that we've tried to
balance but balance in an asymmetric way
because each faction fictionally kind of
has its own strengths and weaknesses
and we wanted to lean into those in
actual gameplay the nice thing the
x-wing has is it's got all three systems
it's got its engines it's got its
lasers and it's got shields you can
shift those double front or behind you
which is something you know we've heard
in the films
but then the tie fighters canonically
don't have shields at all
she said okay what do we do to make that
fair to get to kind of balance these two
ships out but have similar roles but are
on opposite factions and we need to keep
uh
more or less lined up if you fly the two
in our game the x-wing feels a bit
heavier it's got a bit more substance to
it
the tie fighter has zippier turns it's
just a faster ship and a more easily
maneuverable ship and so that helps kind
of counterbalance the shields in and of
itself
but the ability to control the shields
to put them to front or back
is giving another edge to the x-wing so
how do we counter that
what we do is we use the same buttons
that we would use for shield control on
an x-wing
on its high fighter and some of the
other ties we use that for emergency
power conversion
which is the ability to pull all the
juice out of your engines and dump them
into your lasers
or vice versa on the fly so you can
quickly get out of trouble or quickly
juice up your weapons for a massive
attack
in a hurry in a way that the rebel ships
can't some of the things we we had to do
for the x-wing were
changing the viewport kind of slimming
down the struts a bit
it's a bunch of invisible changes that
make it feel like the movie i had to
take the existing dashboard and you know
its angular shape and how how high it is
that's iconic so we obviously had to
have that
we panned and scaled and kind of moved
around to create additional room
so we'd be able to fit all the gameplay
components for each of these
changes basically it's a slide in the
deck showing the original
showing the intended change and
justifying why but
any change we were doing you know using
the materials that were already in the
cockpit you know paint or icons or
buttons that came from elsewhere
and just making sure everything was
really authentic to that that canon ship
we were treating them like
real things right so both from the
fictional standpoint but also as
props for the films we would ask okay
it's 1977 you're at ilm you're building
a prop
you don't have a flat lcd screen those
don't exist yet
you're going to notice that the lights
for your laser charge are actual
leds old style like a little bulb with a
plastic coating over it that's coloring
the light
it's one of those things that makes the
game i think feel more real
because the teams try to approach it as
if it is real if we were making just
any ship just for the game you know from
a player experience standpoint
you're gonna put the the ui element
exactly where you need it the size you
you need it in this case the fantasy is
being a pilot in the star wars universe
so it doesn't make sense to do that
you'd be sacrificing the whole fantasy
that you know we're trying to offer
players because you're just trying to be
as efficient as possible even once we
had the ui there with the right color
scheme and everything
looking great in retro it still wasn't
enough we wanted
players to feel like they were really
there so working with shader artists we
went
and did materials we went to the point
of being able to emulate the screen
resolution for each display
having refresh rates and keeping the
frame rate down to give that retro
choppiness you know like to the
animation
so how do we create the sense that these
ships are real the first thing we did
was the flight model for the x-wing and
tie fighter
and everything's really been built upon
that foundation and what we've tried to
do with them is look at everything we
see in the films even some of the
animated series and so on to look at
what are the boundaries what are these
ships capable of what are they not
capable of
for instance there's no vertical
thrusters on next swing they don't go
straight
up and down that's not a thing that
x-wings do so we did not want that as
part of our flight model because it
doesn't fit the fiction
at the same time we wanted to create the
idea of kind of world war ii
combat piloting as our foundation as it
was for lucasfilm and then from there
go how do we up that a notch how do we
take things like power management and
eventually boost in the drift maneuver
to take it and really take advantage of
the fact that you're in space
and we can do some cool over-the-top
stuff we ended up building an entirely
new
entity to handle how our ships work
within the frostbite engine
because we knew we were trying to do
something that had never been done
before uh in our engine quite like what
we're doing
we base it a lot off of the older games
like the original x-wing and tie fighter
used that as a starting point uh in
terms of the kind of banking maneuvers
we wanted to have in terms of how we
wanted them to handle turns and so on we
did that as a foundation early on and
then we started layering
things in like power management and
eventually the drift maneuver
in legends there was this idea in star
wars of the etheric rudder this idea
that there was some kind of medium in
space that you actually kind of piloted
through
which was sort of the fictional
reasoning behind ships handling more
like aircraft
less like spacecraft now honestly i
don't even know if that's canon anymore
or not but in terms of our
our thinking around how we make the
ships move
it helps as a visual representation of
how ships would move through medium
these are the ships that are meant to go
after other starfighters so they're the
most agile and fast
and they really pack a punch they're
also the most fragile so you have to
watch out they're not meant to go after
capital ships
when going about designing the tie
interceptor the idea was that the tie
fighter the interceptor and the bomber
they're part of the same line when
you're flying imperial there's a certain
standard
there's efficiency in the design but we
did still want each ship to have
its own unique character the way we did
that for the interceptor it's a ship
that's made to hunt
but it's also more fragile so it's a
little details like if you look at the
the viewport the spokes
and then the rim around they're thinner
more refined giving it a more precise
look but also a bit more fragile
and the other big thing that we were
able to use were those screens that were
adding on the side we spoke about
earlier
so each of the three ships got a custom
shape the one for the interceptor are
these kind of aggressive triangles
they kind of cement its look as you know
a hunter so one of the most fun parts of
working on the cockpits for squadrons
was figuring out how you actually fly a
tie fighter
this is true for the fighter the
interceptor and the bomber is that if
you look at the films
we see very little of the actual
interior of those ships and how
physically you control it now an x-wing
uh it's a joystick but with the tie we
see that there's a yoke but it's not
really clear how that works
and so we've ended up with this design
around the pushing and pulling what it
does when you twist like what's a pitch
what's a yaw how do you roll one of
these ships and make sure that what we
do
doesn't contradict what we see in the
films but is internally consistent and
makes sense from a player's standpoint
so if you're playing the game especially
if you're in vr and you look down on
what your pilot's hands are doing
it always makes sense so we built the
ties uh
part of figuring out how they would
control was sort of the physicality of
it
so we actually built simple wooden
armatures that were the controls like
kind of imagine the yoke
of a tie fighter so that then when we
did motion capture performance capture
of our actors for cinematics
they were sitting inside these simple
you know wooden cockpits
and then would work on the motions we're
having a lot of fun with it so one of
the things that makes the thais feel
very distinctive from the new republic
ships and the thai interceptors probably
the best example of this
is actually the sound design so those
core mechanics of you know throttling
your engine and that sweet spot in the
middle of the throttle where you turn
better
those are the same between the factions
but the way we treat that from an audio
standpoint is quite different
you know if you're in a rebel ship if
you listen to it there's rattles and
clanks and clunks and there's this
distinct feeling that there's duct tape
somewhere behind you holding that ship
together
whereas the ties it's it's clean it's
pristine it's precise
especially with the interceptor you're
going to notice higher pitch
you're going to notice more kind of
clean hums very little noise in the mix
the whole idea is that these things are
engineered to perfection
and that's you're experiencing kind of
you know the imperial
cleanliness and design there the a-wing
is one of my favorite ships in all of
star wars so we had a lot of fun
developing it it has that very
aerodynamic shape this thing is just you
know kind of a wedge flying through
space
and yeah i know there's no air in space
but there's always that sensation that
this thing is incredibly fast
at the same time it's pretty small and
you have that that feel that you know
one stray blaster bolt's going to make
your day real bad
and we wanted to capture that in all of
the tuning and design around the a-wing
you look at the rebel ships and you'll
notice that they use different fonts
so we have all these fonts that are from
the indie universe that you've seen on
screen in the movies
we've used them in different
combinations to help the character
of each ship kind of feel a bit
different it takes you know a team uh
you know of experts to bring the ships
to the players like this
one of the things that's fun in the game
is we've been really careful with our
collision
the actual collision geometry around all
the sort of stuff you could smash into
in the game
and as a result if you're in an a-wing
you can pretty easily fly into say the
trench along the side of a star
destroyer
fly into that area that's super tight
but that's a place where you can
legitimately get in there
potentially lose a pursuer as they might
be a bit bigger and smash off the side
we wanted to lean into that idea of
being super fast
super agile but small and you hit like a
truck
so you could have this this crazy
experience of being very cautious as
everything around you can cause your
death pretty easily
but being able to get in and out and do
these awesome hit and fade attacks
that just make you feel like an ace the
cockpit is pretty cramped as well
in vr we had to make a few uh
modifications
there's like this metal rim right that
like runs kind of across like the the
glass
and where it was positioned in the canon
ship it would be in the way of some of
the instruments
that the player needs to to use so we
had to to move it and thin it and kind
of play with that a bit
while still giving you the impression
that it's the the same position the same
look
even being able to let you personalize
it like hanging flair
but not like intrude upon the gameplay
elements well
if this is a real ship that existed and
you got a fuzzy ewok that you wanted to
put in
in the real world somebody would sell an
attachment to actually hook those things
up and so that's what we built
if you look down and it's just like that
classic world war
ii cockpit stuff that you you'd expect
to see it's just a great look it's
the only ship that has a radial speed
gauge with an arrow that actually moves
up and down
and it just gives it that feeling of
speed like almost like a muscle car you
know so
yeah i really enjoyed working on the
a-wing the bombers are defined by being
a bit slower but heavier a bit tankier
built to drop that massive ordinance
that's going to take out big capital
ships things like star destroyers and
mc75s
so they might need a little support
getting there but once they get there
they can do an obscene amount of damage
for the bomber we wanted obviously to
make it look different than the
interceptor and fighter because it has a
very different
role and the exterior is also very
different so we needed to bring that
inside as well for the player
our job was made easier because the
bomber is a bigger ship
so especially when you're looking around
the interior you'll see there's actually
room where people can sit behind you
and all that's designed and looks very
different than the interior from the
other two ships
even if you look to the side you'll see
that there's there's a door
and there's the ordnance you know you
got all the bombs on the other side of
the compartment
so it makes it already feel quite
different just from that
you can actually go against the capital
ships with it you can make serious
damage
it needed to feel tankier kind of the
reverse approach
that we had for the interceptor for the
bomber we went and made
the frames of the viewport thicker more
armored kind of like you could ram
something and really take a lot of
punishment once again those secondary
screens that we introduced
we gave it a different shape for the
bomber something bulkier that just kind
of confirmed its role on the team
the ships that have the off center
cockpit like the bomber or the time
reaper were quite challenging because
as a player you don't want to feel like
all your control is offset by you know a
meter or two from from where the ship's
actually
located it becomes incredibly hard to
tell like can i get through that hole
i don't know where is the hole relative
to me so what we ended up doing is we
have the the
pilot's seat is technically off center
but the pivot point for the ship has
been moved relative to the the broader
shape of the ship
effectively you're driving it from the
center of the ship even though your seat
is a little offset what we do to make
the ships feel weighty is largely
playing with the tuning of their engines
so how fast they accelerate
how fast they decelerate and how much
momentum they preserve when you go into
a different maneuver if you're in a
bomber and you start to turn
the degree to which you have forward
momentum there helps sell that sense
that it's actually kind of a heavy ship
obviously the top end speed relative to
other ships
also helps that sense of weight and
there's a lot of kind of tricks of
presentation that help
it doesn't make a bit of difference in
the way the ship handles but in your
mind
that that sensation that it's a kind of
beefier ship helps make it
feel slower feel weightier similarly
with the sound design
when we're using a lot of lower pitches
that helps kind of correlate your mind
with the slower beefier stronger ship uh
than the more like high-pitched
tightly tuned interceptors so the y-wing
has been a really interesting challenge
for us because we're trying to capture
the the feel of the ship
and it's got a lot of similarities with
the x-wing in terms of its structure and
cockpit
but you still want it to feel
distinctive the cockpit team's done a
great job of looking at the
instrumentation looking at the
shape language that you see within that
dashboard of the film and then trying to
make use of that as well as possible
whether it's the kind of like tube
that works its way over the instruments
or the actual shapes you see of the
instruments there
we try to make use of those and really
lean into them so it feels right
for a y way at the same time kind of
that heavy structure you have around you
around kind of left and right behind you
you have a lot less of a window to your
astromech than you would in say an
x-wing
what's really interesting with the
y-wing is it's one of the the oldest
ships the rebels have
you can definitely see it in the design
so it was quite a challenge for us to
design something that would keep its
unique character but make it
playable because the ship is devoid of
screens for starters like the only one
that you see in the movies
is the targeting computer that comes in
from the side but besides that it
doesn't actually have eight displays
it's kind of like harkens back
to these sci-fi ships that had basically
blinking lights like these huge
computers right with like levers and
blinking lights you look at the wiring
the cabin for the pilot
it's been a versatile ship over
different time periods
and we've even seen it have two two
people in there
having the pilot and having like a rear
gunner so it's a very long cabin
and the pilot is kind of sitting with
like his legs out a bit more compared to
some of the other ships we had to play
you know with like the dimensions and do
a bunch of tricks to make it feel like
the shots especially
the ones you see in episode four but
they make it make it playable so one of
the things we did
was bring in displays that we designed
for the x-wing
and layered them with some of the iconic
things that were in the y-wing like the
tube and then that cone with the glass
lens that we used for the shift status
indicator
even on the screens i paid close
attention to the patterns that you have
on those
side panels like the painting patterns
and those big ribbed glass
lights that kind of stroke we took those
patterns and we made vector versions of
them and we used them as backing for the
information on the displays was
quite a challenge to be able to try and
keep that look
but introduce screens without uh you
know kind of disfiguring the y wing
the y wing for the longest time has been
our example of
how you make two very different builds
using components by default they're
built to be
bombers they're built to be really good
at taking down enemy capital ships
not as good at dog fighting depending on
the components you can slant them very
heavily toward
taking out capital ships and just accept
that you're going to be awful in a
dogfight and need the support of your
friends
or you can slant slanted more the other
way and be more of a heavy assault craft
where you're never going to be as zippy
as an a-wing and you know it's going to
be trouble if people get on your tail
but if they're dumb enough to come at
you from the front you can really end
their day in a hurry
what makes a ship part of the support
class is that you'll be piloting it to
help your friends and hinder your
enemies so you're gonna have a bunch of
tricks up your sleeve that
kind of give you the edge and slow down
your enemies
the thai reaper and the u-wing both of
our support ships actually come from the
film rogue one and we were really
excited to bring them to life in the
game because they haven't had as much
exposure yet
the reaper in particular just you gotta
love that design it's so cool i think
it's probably my favorite ship on the
imperial side
originally we looked at support and we
said okay we want kind of the entry
level class the class that's going to be
the easiest to use it can be helpful for
your team
but isn't as effective at killing did
not work uh for a couple of reasons
first is that the x-wing and the tie
fighter are what everybody knows
so no matter what we do those are going
to be the ships that anybody new or more
casual is going to gravitate toward
the other thing is we found that in a
dog fighter simply you know hunting down
enemies and shooting them
is the most basic thing you can do that
is the most successful and fundamental
part of gameplay
we ended up pivoting our mindset for
support ships
to be less the entry-level ship and
actually the other way around
they're more of a high-level ship that
takes a bit more skill to use
effectively
but they're the specialists you can use
a tie reaper
to sort of batten down the hatches
around your area to put up turrets drop
mines
to defend the zone you can do it to make
your entire team invisible to enemy
radar
to ionize enemy shields and bring them
down to
to uh you know focus fire they're very
versatile in terms of what they can do
with the widest array of different
components that can be equipped we were
bringing a ship to the screen
especially its cockpit that no one had
seen yet so the outside has been seen
but like this is going to be new to our
players there were some models that
existed because the ship
was designed for use for jedi fallen
order our biggest consideration
was uh visibility from the ship we kind
of cut the dashboard
down and made it shorter so the pilot
could sit closer to the front windows
they still look like what you expect
when you're seeing it from the outside
but once again you know through like
little little tricks
uh we make it you know more accessible
for players working on the u-wing has
been interesting because as you may know
it's a two-seater craft
and so trying to balance your
perspective in a way that feels right
that feels like you're in the
left-hand seat across the front there
but also pilots in a way you expect
where it's not difficult to fly through
a hole in a structure because oh
actually my center point is over there
has been really challenging
trying to make sure that our physics
lines up with kind of what your brain
expects as a pilot
especially in vr versus the actual
center point of the ship
the other big challenges as you may know
is that the u-wing has s-foils its wings
unfold
so when the u-wing is jumping into
hyperspace you've got the wings locked
and it's in its iconic u-shape
but once you're ready for combat they
fold back into more of a frankly a y
shape but don't tell the y
wings for combat and that means that
their their breath is quite a bit bigger
so if you're flying through say the
interior of a space station you've got
to be a lot more aware of your
surroundings than that you
than you might need to in something like
an away with both the the u-wing and the
reaper
they have places in them to have whether
it's a co-pilot or passengers in the
back
and if you look inside them in the game
you do see those seats but we don't
actually have them filled
now partially that's because our game is
set in space you're not landing on
planets that
you wouldn't have anywhere to drop them
off not a lot of reason for them to be
there fictionally
but also because from a performance
standpoint the way the game runs
we're trying to make sure we're giving
you the things that matter the most and
giving all the attention there
so the ships and lasers and explosions
are in front of you if we have a high
fidelity character
two feet away from you everything out
the window is gonna have to look worse
in order to make performance space for
that character right next to you
working on the u-wing was easier for two
reasons
one because it's one of the later ships
i tackled in production so we were
already getting
really used to finding creative
solutions to the channels we'd faced on
the other ships
also as luck would have it just the
design with that big central screen and
it has all that you know the mess of
wires and connectors and it has a
secondary monitor
on a swivel i was able to just take that
monitor move it
you know elsewhere where it fit with the
order that we have for components
because every ship is different
but gameplay-wise you know you want
people to to know that the radar is
going to be over on the left the speed
is going to be on the left because it
fits with the controller that kind of
stuff
so that let us easily move it around
without having to modify it as much so
what we did for the ewing is more
rescale and move around existing
elements and we were able to quickly
find a home
for uh for most of our gameplay
components i think for the most part i
only had to modify
the the top part of the central uh
console
so it would uh it would be able to
display our loadout and we used
something that's existing that you saw
like this kind of glass part with red
lights in the movie
it was close enough to our laser bar so
it was a really
a good fit so we've added these two new
ships
the thai defender and the b-wing we
designed the game around the eight core
playable ships
but fortunately thanks to all the
support of our players we're able to add
these entirely new ships
that fill new niches within the gameplay
and we think they're gonna add a lot to
the game
even though the ships are part of
existing classes they play very
differently they're quite unique and
they get their own unique components as
well
a big part of the design of squadrons is
about team composition and the way that
you kind of lay out your team and the
way that you support each other like
okay you know i'm going to need some
people that are handling just enemy
ships and i need some people that are
focusing on the objectives and so on
if we added a whole new class like we
called them the the heavy or something
that compositional picture got a bit
more complicated so instead we went how
do we fit these into the existing kind
of roles that we have
but offset enough in that kind of
spectrum of design
that they all feel unique we don't want
the the thai defender to feel like
it's a tie fighter with a different
cockpit you want it to feel distinctive
but we still want to understand the role
that okay
this is a flexible ship that can be used
both offensively and defensively
in the way that a tie fighter would i'm
a big fan of it from the thai fighter
days like the pc game tie fighter we
were so excited to see that come back
into canon and
okay well we gotta let people fly this
thing the reason we put it in that kind
of fighter class
is that it is meant to be flexible it's
something that can help offensively
defensively
where it's a bit different than say the
tie fighter or thai interceptor
is it's really good within a given area
it's not as good at getting from point
to point
heavily leans on boost and drift for all
your maneuverability
so you can really hold a spot but if you
need kind of superiority over a large
space to hold the front
you don't want to rely just on defenders
you're going to mix that up with a
different team composition
the tie defender being part of the same
you know line as the tie fighter bomber
or interceptor
obviously has to have a lot of things in
common with them
that's kind of the point with that
series for the pilots to just hop in
you know your home all the ships in the
series the main difference was
the viewports and also the secondary
monitors that we have on both sides of
that
central column that's standard in all of
them so the tie defender still has that
console in the middle and it has its own
set of handles on the side
one big thing with a tie defender is it
has shields
so it means it has more power management
going on and also has
more information that you need to be
able to consult as a player as you're
flying that then ship we had fun playing
with different shapes and patterns and
we found one that both felt robust
enough
to kind of feel like this is a ship that
can take punishment but also
still felt aggressive a bit closer to
the tie interceptor than the bomber
let's say
we want it to look like the empire spent
more money on this ship there's a little
bit more technology going on a little
bit more stuff
built in compared to the other three
core tie fighters the ship status
indicator if you look at the other
three basic ties besides the reaper what
we're showing you is the silhouette
of the the ship seen from the front
because the defender has shields
we wanted to show you a top-down view so
it would be clear right off the bat
you're looking at your front and rear
shields
i love its silhouette so aggressive with
all those those spikes
when you see from the top but it's also
a very challenging shape to work with
uh for the ui to try and you know like
surround it with the shields
and fit that nicely within the screen so
i spent
you know quite a bit of time doing
different iterations and patterns and
and line art to that would uh that would
really go well with the silhouette and
still stay clear for the player
in rebels the tie defender is just
straight up better than the other ties
in the context of a competitive game
that doesn't work great it's like all
right well you've got five ships take
that one it's completely superior
so what we've done lore wise is that
after thrawn's initiative uh you know
spoilers where things go sideways on
lothal bad defender
initiative is put out of service but the
plans are still around
so in our time period when the empire is
not doing so well
the plan still exists but they don't
have the resources they once did so
you're getting kind of a second
generation
more suited for mass production version
the whole game was designed to make you
feel like an ace pilot but the defender
is a whole other level
now i'm the elite within the ace pilot
group when i really master that ship
which is a great feeling
the cool thing about the b-wing is it's
the last ship from the return of the
jedi era that we wanted to bring to the
light
that we never got a chance to do with
the core game so the b-wing is really
cool because it's got this unique
gyroscopic cockpit you can actually keep
your cockpit stable
but control the entire rest of the ship
around the cockpit now partially this is
just
cool just for fun but also you can be
using this tactically so it's something
that improves your missile evasion it's
something you can use to aim your bombs
so you can have your ship like aiming
upward fly under a ship and shoot your
bomb straight up for example and beyond
that
it actually is increasing the rest of
your ammo so if you take that component
the one that lets you control your
gyroscopic cockpit
it's doubling whatever your other
auxiliary does so we were wondering
maybe
we would only allow you to have it
vertically or horizontal
and it would just kind of ease by itself
in between those motions once you
triggered it
or we could allow total control i'm
pretty pretty stoked that we're actually
able to allow you granular control so
you can actually place it at any angle
that you want as you're piloting we
decided to go kind of old school with a
dial that looks like some
something you'd have on an old fighter
plane and you actually have a needle
that's like a viewing silhouette shape
and you see it rotate around the dial so
you get like this precise feedback
you've got a bubble cockpit so if you're
doing free look or especially if you're
in vr
you could be just looking you know out
the window as that as that big wing is
moving along you'll see it like you know
block out the light
like across your dashboard you feel the
rumble if you're using a controller
you've got that kind of
shuttering metal scraping sound as the
entire ship moves around
you can be firing your lasers your beam
cannon or whatever while
you're rotating the wing as you see the
lasers kind of spiraling around your
cockpit
as that's rotating and you're still
firing this ship is ungainly you go
flying into a tight tunnel like in our
new map foster haven you got to really
be paying attention to where the
constraints of that ship are you smack
into a wall
and so having that that level of
situational awareness having the new
instrumentation once you actually
control and be aware of where the rest
of your ship is
uh is a whole new kind of experience
with the b-wing that's really unlike
anything else in the game
the references we had were mainly the
ships were built
for the original trilogy so you've never
seen them
in the movie like the inside but they
were built
like as part of that that ship they were
using for those outside shots as they
were flying through space
and then uh there was references from
the rubble's show for the prototype of
the b-wing from a fictional standpoint
the blade wing was the prototype so what
we're trying to capture is more of
the standard b-wing that comes along a
bit later and also because
there's just something cool about
feeling like when you saw return of the
jedi
that cockpit was actually there in that
b wing you just couldn't quite see it
because of the camera work
and we're finally getting to sort of
reveal that to the world you know very
much in first person
for the first time the b wing being one
of the later ships to be uh
introduced it's little subtle things
that will set it apart
making the screens a bit higher
resolution and playing you know with the
the type of crt or lcd monitors you're
seeing in some of the panels the beaming
has a mix
of like small crts for like its radar
and then the ship status indicator
but then it does have a nice big lcd
display for the combat screen closer to
what you'd see on the the u-wing
so the b-wing in lore is is a bomber you
know it's it's a bomber flash assault
craft but being
being a great bomber is a big part of
its identity so we wanted to keep that
concept
um but it's also such a unique ship you
know it's something that a lot of people
a lot of our fans have wanted to play
we've got a lot of feedback of the
b-wing where is it
okay we put it in guys gonna be okay
it's that idea of being able to control
your bombs
specifically that from a mechanical
standpoint fit well with the ship
we thought that was such a good fit that
it made sense to really lean into that
bomber role
the other thing is if you look at the
design of our ships the y-wing has
always been intended to be kind of a
spectrum
between going all bomber and more of a
dogfighter or somewhere in between we
give you quite a bit of flexibility
with the b-wing we've gone even further
to the right so it can dog fight but at
the most it's going to be a backline
fighter that's kind of providing
to give it like artillery support
whereas on the other extreme it is a
bomber
that is good for dropping bombs and
nothing else and you darn well better
escort it in terms of team composition
the thing with the b-wing
is that it is the farthest thing over in
the extreme of kind of the
i just murder people to i just murder
capital ships uh spectrum
of our different ships and so it's
something that doesn't work well on its
own this is a ship that benefits
tremendously from being paired with the
u-wing and to a lesser extent by being
paired with other ships that can support
and protect it
on its way to the desk to the
destination similarly you can set it up
to be more of a dog fighter
but even in that case it's not going to
be flying around in the middle of
everything the way that an a-wing would
it stays more at a distance and while
everyone else is keeping the enemy busy
it just guns them down you know
tremendous artillery so it's
very much a ship that leans into
teamwork you don't want to run b-wings
without the support of your buddies
[Music]
and that was every starfighter in star
wars squadrons
we hope this has helped you understand
the game a little bit better and brought
that galaxy far far away
a little bit closer to home